fünf Tage sind es noch dann geht
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine ein
Jahr lang und Putins großes Ziel zum
Jubiläumstag also zum einjährigen
Jubiläum seiner Invasion der Ukraine ist
die Eroberung von bachmut der Großstadt
im Osten des Landes die an der Front
sich hier befindet in der Region Donezk
und wir wissen bereits seit Monaten seit
September spätestens stehen seine
Truppen direkt vor bachmut versuchen
diese Stadt zu erobern und es sieht so
aus wir können das einmal hier markieren
es sieht so aus als würde dieses große
Ziel nicht gelingen denn die Ukraine
versucht alles um bachmut ihm zu
verteidigen und um diese riesige
Propaganda Erfolg diese Propaganda
Aufnahmen der russischen Armee nicht zu
geben um eben nicht sagen zu können seht
ihr auch im zweiten Jahr werden wir
weiter Erfolge feiern auch im zweiten
Jahr werden wir weiter ukrainische
Großstädte erobern und insofern
versuchen sie alles um machen Mut hier
zu verteidigen und wir haben neue
Aufnahmen die wollen uns einmal ansehen
einmal direkt aus der Stadt und einmal
aus dem Umfeld der Stadt und wir können
dort erklären warum
eben Putin alles versucht dort weiter
vorzurücken und was die Ukraine dagegen
macht wir haben erstmal diese Aufnahmen
das sind Nachtaufnahmen insofern ein
bisschen schwierig zu erkennen aber wir
haben hier tatsächlich Wohnbezirke von
bachmut und wir können uns hier das
einmal kurz ansehen was wir hier sehen
das ist die Bewegung das sind die
russischen Söldner der Wagener Truppe
die sich nach vorne bewegen und die
relativ präzisia angegriffen werden von
der ukrainischen Armee wir sehen wie sie
sich bewegen und das Wichtige ist eben
wir befinden uns hier tatsächlich in den
Straßen von bachmut das ist kein Vorort
sondern das ist im östlichen Teil der
Stadt wenn wir jetzt gleich raussuchen
dann können wir uns das noch mal ganz
genau angucken das also jetzt ganz kurz
zu sehen hier also vorne Garagen hier
sehr große Häuser und hier haben wir
dieses wirklich komplexe Straßensystem
was ich eben bewegt innerhalb der Stadt
hier ist auch noch eine große Straße das
also tatsächlich Bach Mut an sich bei
Nacht und dort versuchen Russland zu
werden weil sie den Befehl haben eben
bachmut zu erobern das ist ganz
wichtiges Ziel nicht unbedingt vom Putin
selber aber von
ihrem Chef dem Putin Freund der ihm
gesagt hat wir müssen Putin dieses
Geschenk machen wir müssen zum Jahrestag
ihm zeigen dass wir eben in der Lage
sind weiter vorzurücken und Großstädte
zu erobern und wir wissen die Wagner
Söldner haben Mitte Januar ihre erste
Stadt erobert Sole da Solidar allerdings
im Vergleich zu bachmut eine Kleinstadt
oder da genau 10.000 Einwohner hat Mut
vor dem Krieg natürlich über 70.000
Einwohner man schätzt das etwa 5000
Menschen dort noch leben in den in den
Ruinen bzw in den weniger stark
betroffenen westlichen Stadtteilen die
unter ukrainischer Kontrolle sind wie
gesagt das hier also das Bild in
ostenbach-muth man muss sich wie gesagt
ein bisschen drauf konzentrieren weil es
sind in der Nachtaufnahmen aber man
sieht hier wirklich hunderte Häuser und
wir sehen dass sie Russen sich langsam
fortbewegen dass sie also von Haus zu
Haus sich weiter bewegen vor allem
nachts das ist wie gesagt ihre ihr ihre
Strategie in letzter Zeit in der
Hoffnung dass man nachts nicht so gut
sehen kann und wir sehen ja auch es ist
schwer zu sehen für die ukrainische
Drohne und wir sehen auch dass wir es
nicht mit Infrarot Aufnahmen zu tun
haben das heißt auch diese Drohne ist
tatsächlich auf Tageslicht angewiesen
und versucht eben das Mörser und
Artillerie Feuer der ukrainischen Armee
noch irgendwie zu dirigieren während sie
diese dunklen Punkte diese Wagner
Söldner die sich hier bewegen hier sehen
wir sie wieder von von einem Ort zum
anderen sich bewegen ja solange sie die
Drohne das noch sieht kann sie diese
Daten weitergeben wenn es dann gleich
Nacht wird und die die überhaupt kein
Licht mehr da ist wird es umso
schwieriger für die Drohne weil wir
sehen hier noch mal keine Infrarot
Aufnahmen dunkle Punkte sind die
Menschen wären das Infrarot Aufnahmen
während helle Punkte da würden wir also
als helle Punkte wegen aufgrund der
Wärme die Menschen hier sehen das also
die Situation innerhalb von bachmut und
wir wollen jetzt aber auch noch einmal
erstmal eine Karte ansehen wie denn die
Schlacht Umbach muss ich auf der Karte
darstellt und warum die nächsten fünf
Tage die fünf Tage bis zum Jahrestag von
Russland Krieg eben hier absolute ja
absolut essentiell sind bachmut hier
einmal zu sehen in Rot zu sehen dass
bereits von Russland eroberte Gebiet und
wir sehen
die Aufnahmen die wir eben gesehen haben
stammen von hier aus dem Osten von
bachmut dort versucht die russische
Armee im in der Stadt weiter
vorzudringen und sich in der Stadt
weiter in Richtung Zentrum zu bewegen
wir haben aber eben auch die
Zangenbewegung Russlands und die
zangenbewegungen hat in den letzten
Tagen bzw gerade gestern dieses Gebiet
noch mal komplett unter Kontrolle
gebracht auch das ist jetzt russisch
besetzt von krass nach hora ist sind die
russischen Truppen hier nach Westen
vorgedrungen und versuchen jetzt eben
diesen diese Zangenbewegung hier
vorzunehmen um den Nachschub
abzuschneiden und um eben die Großstadt
wir sehen ja das aller größten Teil ich
würde sagen 95% der Stadt sind noch
unter Ukraine ich habe Kontrolle aber
eben das Umland nur noch zu weniger als
der Hälfte und nicht bloß dort oben bei
krass sondern auch hier unten bei
ivaniske versucht die russische Armee
vorzudringen und ähm das ist besonders
wichtig für die Ukraine weil sie sich
hier um eine der letzten Straßen handelt
hier versucht also die russische Armee
hier vorzudringen und eben diese Zange
diesen Kessel vom bachmut zu schließen
und wir sehen jetzt Aufnahmen wie die
Ukraine versuchen das zu verhindern
nämlich das sind ganz neue Ausnahmen
Aufnahmen aus der Nähe von ivaniske und
wir sehen hier ukrainische Panzer
übrigens von Russland abbeutete Panzer
und auch verschiedene gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge aus den USA und aus
Großbritannien die hier vordringen und
tatsächlich versuchen die russischen
Truppen die versuchen Bachem Mut zu
flankieren und diesen Kessel eben
einzurichten die die angreifen wir sehen
also tatsächlich wie der Panzer immer
wieder auf die Wälder schießt dort
gerade in diesen Böschungen entlang der
der Wälder eben zwischen diesen großen
Feldern bewegen sich die russische
Truppen und wir sehen wie der Panzer
tatsächlich alle ja alle 10 Sekunden
ungefähr in diesen Wald hineinschießt
das heißt wir haben hier einen ganz
geringe Entfernung hier der T-72 den wir
gerade gesehen haben hier also der Wald
und hier drinne ähm ja verstecken sich
die russischen Söhne die eben versuchen
ähm bachmut einzukesseln und bei ivanist
gehe eben diese wichtige
Verbindungsstraße dort zu besetzen
das also wirklich Aufnahmen die jetzt
vor wenigen Tagen erst entstanden sind
und wo die Ukraine eben versuchen auf
jeden Fall noch bis zum 24 oder am
besten natürlich noch viel länger diese
ivanistik hier zu verteidigen den
Eingang zu bachmut zu verteidigen den
westlichen Eingang um eben dort weiter
Nachschub in die Stadt zu kriegen das
also die Information dass also die Lage
und die Information aktuell aus Bach Mut
wir wollen aber noch mal weitergehen und
wir wollen uns noch mal ansehen wie
beide Seiten Drohnen einsetzen das äh
ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema Drohnen
sind essentiell in diesem Krieg wie wir
wissen und wir gucken uns jetzt erst
einmal an wie die Ukraine die Drohnen
einsetzen und das geht hier sehr früh
los deshalb müssen wir gleich mal
anhalten das hier ist wie man so oft
sieht eine ein russischer Graben eine
russische Stellung und was wir hier
gerade sehen was hier abgeworfen wird in
der Mitte ist da ist sehen wir es ist
eine Handgranate die also in den Graben
hinein geworfen wird das Besondere ist
das sehen wir jetzt gleich dass die
Drohne das nicht hier alleine macht
sondern die agiert und kämpft direkt in
Koordination mit Bodentruppen mit
ukrainischen Soldaten
die hier unten auch vorrücken das heißt
wir sehen hier die Granate die reingeht
in das Loch und jetzt ziehen wir es ein
bisschen raus mit der Kamera und wir
sehen und das ist ganz spannend da
gerade den Granaten Einschlag hier das
sind ukrainische Soldaten diese
ukrainischen Soldaten also plus einige
Meter neben dieser Explosion versuchen
hier vorzudringen und wir sehen jetzt
gleich wie sie in diesen da sehen wir es
noch mal diese also von hier in das Loch
rein schießen wo sich russische Soldaten
verstecken was eben gerade angegriffen
wurde also mit anderen Worten einen
tatsächlichen präzisionsangriff der
ukrainischen Drohne die aufpassen muss
dass sie nicht die eigene Männer trifft
und wir sehen uns jetzt der russische
Soldat ist ja ist hier ja äh
höchstwahrscheinlich tot und die kann
nicht nur Soldaten haben es eben
zusammen mit der Drohne geschafft die
erstmal die Explosion da hervorruft den
Russen ablenkt und jetzt sehen wir wie
dort durchgeschossen wird und der Russe
dort ausgeschaltet wird das also ein
präzisionsangriff der ukrainischen
Drohne gegen eine russische Stellung und
jetzt sehen wir uns das ganze auch
andersrum an denn nicht um die Ukraine
haben präzisionsdrohen sondern auch die
Russen wir wissen dass die landset
Kamikaze Drohne eine der besten Drohnen
ist die die russische Armee überhaupt
besitzt eine besten kamikazedonen mit
bis zu 40 km Reichweite und was wir
unten sehen ist ein amerikanisches
Geschütz vom Typ m77 und das Besondere
ist dass dieses Geschütz hier bereits
geschützt ist von einem Anti drohnennetz
wir sehen das hier relativ gut rüber da
also ein Anti drohnennetz was dort extra
aufgespannt wurde um eben die russischen
Kamikaze Drohne abzuhalten aber wir
sehen leider in dem Fall für die Ukraine
hat dass diese Drohne hier ein sehr sehr
ein sehr sehr große Präzision hat und
genau von vorne hinein fliegt in die
Stellung wo also das Netz nicht gespannt
ist wir lassen es einfach mal laufen
anhalten
das also genau der Moment des
Einschlages hier haben wir das geschützt
vom Typ m77 hier oben haben wir den das
das anti-drohnennetz und insofern findet
dieser Einschlag tatsächlich genau von
vorne statt genau da statt in dem Moment
wo eben oder in diesem kleinen Teil wo
die Stellung nicht vom Anti drohnennetz
beschützt ist das also ein großes
Problem für die ukrainische Armee die
weiteren aufpassen muss und sich auch
Wege überlegen muss wie sie diese
russischen drohen diese Kamikaze drohen
die extrem präzise
angreifen können eben aufhalten kann
diese Anti drohnennetze scheinen dort
bloß bedingt zu helfen sondern die
Ukraine braucht andere Mittel um eben
sich gegen die russischen Drohnen zu
wehren